question one now I was doing at the
reference sheet before if there's one
question where the reference you would
be useful this would be it however I've
pointed out as much as you can you
should not rely on the reference sheet
something like this it's not that
complicated
what do you think let's look all right
you can see I've included this line it
wasn't really necessary in this case I
think most people I think most people
could sort of work that out
however sometimes you'll get something
which is significantly Messier for
instance if you get something like oh I
don't know
here's an example 64 8 to 6 plus okay so
when you look at that okay actually now
let me let me change that change that to
a 9 so when you look at a question like
this you're like oh wait what am i what
am i cubing again I know about sums of
cubes okay
so writing this writing the next line
like what is cube to get 64 it's it's 4
right what's cute to get AC a to the
power 6 H squared right so that thing is
cute so now you know what's being cubed
and there's another kind of bowing to
you which is that you look at 9 and
you're like I am 3 right except no not 3
because 9 is not a cubic number I don't
see like ah jerks okay so what you would
have to do is there's a couple ways you
do this you could say the cube root of 9
you could you could just write that you
could simplify a little further if you
like but you're still going to have some
we don't indices in there baby
and that gets cute okay so you can see
when you get a messy a question like
this like I can ask a question like this
and I printed the style paper I can ask
a question like this and I will put it
at the end of the paper it's the same
skill but it's depending on whether I
want to give you an easy one or a hard
one when it's harder clearly there is a
benefit to run this intermediate line do
you see that so that's why I put it in
even though this one is pretty
so X minus 3x squared plus 3x plus 9
give a tick or don't give it a tick if
the person in front is you've got
something else
please write in the correct solution for
them let's have a look at number two
okay now I've gone before you here the
way that I approach all of these
inequality questions which is to draw a
picture now you can see it's over here
on the left hand side it doesn't have to
be more beautiful or neat I'm just lucky
that's my iPad just ignores the straight
lines below me but if you are this is
you know not super accurate okay you
just need enough to be able to say oh I
want where the absolute value of X minus
3 is less than or equal to 1 that's all
you need to say oh I'm underneath I'm
between these two boundaries and then
you just have to find those others okay
so because it's an Isis straight it's a
linear function it's quite easy to read
off 2 & 4 as your boundaries so this is
the solution there's one thing and then
secondly here is the graph of the
solution so this would be too much you
get one mark for the inequality or
stadia get a second mark for the Jordan
this is a senator now the way to
recognize that it's a semicircle is for
starters just look at the equation first
do you notice even though it's not
stated there is actually a restriction
on what Y can be Y can't be anything
right I've got the square root here on
the right hand side right which I think
Aragon's the question a week or two ago
now what's this mean the square root of
something is defined as positive do you
agree with that okay the square root of
25 is not plus or minus 5 it's just fine
okay so therefore you have this range
restriction in fact it's helpful to
write up the top there even if you don't
necessarily have to because then when
you go to the next line you're like what
am I gonna do that I'll square
everything if you square the left and
right hand sides that is still true
except this second line here you have
lost information
the second line doesn't tell you that Y
has to positively just on this line here
why can't be negative you can put
negative numbers in there and it's fine
you'd get the bottom half in the semi
circle then when you look at this you
say okay well the next line I guess
sorry let's move this out of the way the
next line would be you add x squared to
both sides and you're like oh yeah I
recognize that it has a center at the
origin and it has a radius of five okay
but then you come back to the first line
you say it's not a circle it's not a
circle it's going in the top huh does
that make sense so you should have a a
nice neat line through there they would
pay attention to your shape that's not a
parabola therefore you'd actually do get
if you were to draw a line right up
against the sides of the circle and the
top it should be vertical and horizontal
respectively
so now gradient is important you can't
hit the axes like this right so you can
see that there that's a dead giveaway
that you don't really know what the
shape is because you haven't drawn it as
a semi circle that's not a semi circle
okay so you've got champagne you should
have intercepts there are three of them
and they're very easy to find one last
little bit it's not so important you
certainly lose mods but you should do it
this graph has endpoints like it
actually stops it doesn't keep on going
forever so it's kind of nice and handy
to actually put some markers on the end
there and then filled circles why they
filled circles are not say for instance
hollow circles yeah
very good as you look back at the
previous question a filled circle means
two is included and four is included if
I had followed circles like this I would
be the region or that line but not two
and not fall okay in exactly the same
way when you come to look at the
semicircle
this means that parts included sometimes
it would be we'll look at this examples
later on but in this case it is alright
let's have a look down key you might
have looked at full-auto gross let's
start pairing but it's just collecting
like terms that's all it is there X
Squared's are highlighted them there XY
z-- that's all there's to it here's my
solution to the algebraic equation can I
get some knots of agreement for some
shapes ooh okay good excellent you can
see the way that I've done it is I've
multiplied through by X plus 3 X minus 5
once I've multiplied through I've been
expanded now can I just um point out for
you I don't know when I see something
like this my instinct is as I've been
trained to go this times that times that
and then go this times that times that
and that's fine give you the right
answer okay but look at this this is a
factorized quadratic we spend lots and
lots of time turning these into these
how do we do it what parrot but how do
we work out what these pairs of numbers
up
very good fantastic so you're thinking
of a pair of numbers that adds to the
you seven multiplies to positive 10 and
that's how you get those numbers so
therefore all we have to do you don't
have to like work out they click like
tones are they going to be you just look
at these and say well they add to NICU
seven and they multiply to ten and the
same thing over there okay it's just a
little thing you're very good at this so
just use that skill you already have
I've collected my terms and then I've
divided through that's it
the most common error on this question
is negative 7 negative 7 because we're
so used to divide in big numbers by
small numbers and not recognizing well
there's nothing wrong with dividing a
small number by a big number it's just
even real like we don't have that as
much okay these are 6 now you can see
again I've had to factorize that
quadratic I factorize the denominator as
well and then you have this thing
it cancels which is convenient which is
one of the ways you're like oh yeah cool
I'm on the right track I just want to
point out one extra thing that I've got
anyone has if they do super thumbs up
I'm impressed
how many of you did anyone write that
anyway okay I'm not surprised and you
wouldn't lose a mug for it in this
context however I'm gonna ask all of you
right now to write it on to your friends
paper because two reasons number one
it's true and can't equal one and I know
that from this factorize line in here M
can equal one there's another thing can
equal to you by the way what is that it
can't be equal zero or either okay now I
want you think about why so let us
denominator up okay now why dad both the
same is at the end to go from the second
line to the third line these are
algebraically equivalent okay if I put a
number like say M equals five if I put
it into here and then evaluate it I'd
get the same thing exactly as if I put
into here and then evaluated so
algebraically they are equivalent
however this line has is there some
information
from this line that is present in this
lab namely when you see that n minus 1
on the denominator
you know M can't equal 1 right but once
you cancel it out that information
disappears it's a little bit like when I
said this if you take the square root of
a square number right you're going to
get something out the other end you
might think oh it's a right because
we're squaring their opposite but it's
not a do you remember what the
definition is
that's the absolute value of variables
right so they're going from this line
sorry this is the quick expression to
this expression ah the algebraic way the
same right you put a number in the left
hand side and get then safety on the
right hand side but the right hand side
strips of ways of information you don't
know where that a was positive or not
does that make sense and it's the same
thing with this slide those restrictions
don't matter really at the moment
because who cares what M is
it doesn't matter of just simple plain
but later on it really does matter so
that's why I think this is a helpful
thing to get right we're almost at the
end in fact we can pretty much do these
two together the factorization is pretty
straightforward group common factors you
get difference of squares and out pops
your factorization at the end when you
simplified down here you had to remember
how to work with these Serbs we haven't
looked at bad recently I'll address that
later this lesson I will talk about it
recently then you have to collect some
like tones because it'll go right and
he's the longest question again you had
to multiply through this time they were
notion of nuts and then you collect my
terms at the end